so all that happened while I was
pregnant so it kind of to me was like oh
y'all playing with me like and and your
your hormones are going crazy well
that's why I left them to begin with
this because so I was pregnant he's not
coming home he's acting a fool he's not
doing the most so I just left I'm just
going through a lot I took his car I
took his car and I just went to my mom's
what you gonna do now right now I'm
saying this this is and that now what I
told her for like a week I probably that
whole a week she'd been gone I probably
hit her like three times like come on
come back you ain't gotta do this right
I so did after a week she like uh I've
been looking at this place I'm gonna go
do this I'm gonna go do that I was that
mad oh my damn all right
so then right that's how I got stuck
with rock cause I'm all right
you come uh you in the game now you're
in the game now come on
again come on like you're in you're in
I'm a high school football I'm a high
school football coach you feel me yeah
that's how I'm out here coaching
Mighty Mites